All right. What's going on guys?
This is Rob and after the season finale of the Mandalorian,
right. Which was amazing.
I had been Jonesy for star Wars and here's the funny thing.
I've kind of really been wanting to cover star Wars for a while now. Right?
Like especially the Mandalorian Wars. I really feel like we should cover that.
Technically it's, there's not really like a Mandalorian Wars comic series,
right? Like it's covered in essentially the old Republic comics,
but it's more of like a background event.
But if anybody has any particular comics that like point directly in, you know,
to like the Mandalorians like anybody know anything about the Mandalorian
comics, send them to me, like post them in the comments and like,
I will cover it because do the man, I love the idea of the Mandalorians.
They're like basically the star Wars version of like Spartans from like ancient
Greece, right. Greek Spartans. So I'm, I'm, I'm covering,
what's probably the coolest moment ever in Darth Vader where he faces off
against like 150 like rebels, right? Like, like rebel soldiers,
whatever you want to call them, rebel volunteers,
the events of this particular story Bader down,
this takes place in the aftermath of a new hope. Right?
So like the destruction of the first death start. And as you guys know,
from seeing like a new hope that when Luke Skywalker showed up on the scene,
Bader was like, dude, okay. It's like this guy,
this guy has got the force with him and like, sort of realizing, okay,
there's something about this kid and all that kind of stuff.
And then of course we know that it's not until empire strikes back that Vader
confronted Luke Skywalker with the revelation that Darth Vader was Luke
Skywalker's dad. Right? And so because of that,
Vader is on the hunt for Luke Skywalker, right? He's on the hunt for this kid,
trying to find them.
Now Darth Vader is traveling to this planet called ragas Voss,
which is as far as he's aware,
the last known location of where Luke Skywalker was,
and this information comes by way of a woman named Dr. Afra.
Now Dr. Afra is a really, really cool character.
She's basically like the star Wars version of Indiana Jones. Like the hook,
her comic stories are amazing. It's so cool.
And essentially what had happened was that she was kind of greeted by Darth
Vader and then she was offered to join Darth Vader side,
no for particular cause and mission that he was going on.
The funny thing about this is that she's got two droids. Uh,
one is called [inaudible] and the other one is triple zero.
They're like murderous versions of C3 PO and R2D2 is effectively what they are.
They're hilarious. They're droids are amazing in the end,
he's given us information. This is where we believe Luke Skywalker's at,
as far as we're aware, it's a dead world.
You should be able to track them down pretty quickly,
grab the kid and then bring him to the service of the emperor. Right?
Because as we know at this point in the story, in terms of Luke,
Luke Skywalker's history,
he's nowhere near capable of going toe to toe with dark Vader, right?
It's not until he gets to Doug Bubba during empire strikes back that he actually
starts to get to the point where he could basically present himself as any
measure of a challenge to Vader. Because of that,
as soon as Vader comes out of hyper-speed, he arrives at,
at voguers Voss and is immediately met with like 36 X wings that were not
supposed to be there. Right. The information that they had with, like,
there was nobody there. There's nothing there.
Now these guys are here and you could call it luck of the draw,
but does look really have anything to do with it.
Like you end up confronting Darth Vader, like it's bad luck of the draw, right?
Like they're literally just on like some regular routine missions, right.
Just kind of doing their thing going on drills effectively. Right.
And they're just kind of canvassing the area and making sure that nobody's
supposed to be there. Who's not supposed to be there.
And as soon as they see a tie fighter, they don't that it's Darth Vader, man.
Let me tell you so right.
What you are about to see here is quite possibly one of the most
spectacular whippings in the history of star Wars, right.
They immediately jammed the frequencies of the sky and it's like, okay,
wherever this Thai fighter is, we don't know how he got here.
He's way too far to be out here by himself. Right?
So there's probably a fleet somewhere around here,
somewhere jammies communications.
So we can't go back and report to anybody because we're rebels, right?
We're literally a militia force running on a shoestring budget.
So they immediately jammed the communications a Bader.
But because of the fact of the communication start getting disrupted,
Vader's initial thought is that it was,
it was possibly a trap set up by Afra and goes, as far as the teller,
like if this was a trap, you would better hope it kills me.
Because if I find out that you set this trap up,
I'm going to come back and there's nowhere in the galaxy, you can hide, right?
Like there's nowhere you can go. I will find you.
And I will make you beg for death. Right. Which is exactly what he would do.
And so she's like, no, I'm not that crazy. Right?
Like there's no circumstance where I would like screw you over like that. Right.
Like I know who you are. I know what you're capable of.
And so it's one of these things where Bader basically picks up on the idea.
He begins to sense Luke Skywalker through the force that he is actually on this
planet. And so initially like she tells him like, you have to run.
And he's like, I'm the Lord of the set. So Dorothy was like,
I'm not running anywhere. Right.
They're the ones who should be running now for all these Webelos here in these X
wings, as far as they're aware, it's your standard,
Imperial pilot flying some Thai fighter. This, this guy is like,
it's literally a cakewalk to destroy a rebel. Pilar, I'm sorry. Uh, uh,
an Imperial pilot in a tie fighter with all these guys here.
But here's the thing, man, this is Vader, right? Like one of the,
probably the single greatest pilot in the entirety of the galaxy, right.
This guy comes flying right through. As soon as these X wings open fire,
he's like he's behind them before they even knew what happened and just starts
ripping them apart. Right. I mean, just new just starts crushing these guys.
Right. Just obliterated them from every direction.
They have no idea what's coming. Right. Like as soon as they turn around,
he's already on the offensive coming right back at him again.
And they're like all units attack. Right? And like,
they start to get off because they're like, who in the hell is flying?
This thing is one of them is like a dead man. It's Darth Vader son.
So like as soon as they start started,
start attacking him because of the fact that he's got deflector shields, right.
He's able to effectively deflect pretty much all the shots they fire on him.
And he just starts picking him apart piece by piece. This is insane.
This is probably the most spectacular living ever in the history of star Wars.
Not even in hell. Would you see a massacre like this? Right?
Like these guys are getting obliterated.
And the funny thing about it is they never even had a chance.
These guys started locking on torpedoes to destroy the destroy,
the tie fighter and Darth Vader just like reaches out with the force and sends
the torpedoes off in all these different directions and just keeps on coming
light. Just keeps on ripping these guys up now while that's going on,
Luke Skywalker is part of, part of, of red group. Right.
You guys know that from, from episode four, Luke,
Skywalker's out there watching all this happen. Right. And he's just like, okay,
that's Darth Vader. And they're, they're like, wait a minute. Like,
are you talking to like V Darth Vader? It's like,
do you know of another Darth Vader? What other Darth Vader in this galaxy?
Are you aware of? Who flies a tie fighter? It's insane. Right.
It's it's kind of, okay. So like as soon as he's like, it's Vader right there,
just kind of, well, it doesn't really matter who it is.
Like we're going to take them out and it's like, no, you can't. Right? Like,
like Bader is ridiculously capable. He's got the power of the force.
We can't defeat him like this. Right.
We can't go flying in with X wings and destroy Vader because you'll kill us all.
So Luke Skywalker, like literally just like, does this kamikaze run? Right.
It's the craziest thing. And he has this plan, right. He's banking on this idea.
He goes flying in towards Darth Vader and he just kind of lets, you know,
he basically tells like our two like close comps, right.
Shut off communications. And it's like, okay.
And so Darth Vader sees Luke Skywalker initially and doesn't realize it's him
and fixes just like some crazy guy who wants to go toe to toe with Vader. Right.
You just kinda like a worthy opponent. Cool.
And then immediately he senses the fact that it's Luke and he's like Holy cow.
So Luke basically uses the connection between Bader and himself through the
forest to, to momentarily distracted crashes,
headlong into Darth Vader and sends him flying down into the world. Right now,
Luke Skywalker goes crashing down to you.
And the initial fear is that Luke Skywalker died, right?
Like the other rebels are,
are basically afraid that Luke Skywalker could have possibly died here.
The other part of this is that Bader realizing it's Luke kind of makes us
offhanded remark. If he is truly strong in the force, this will not end him.
Now, remember this is kind of a tenant of the Sith, right?
The idea that only the strong deserve to survive, right?
Like the rule of two that you have a master and you have an apprentice when the
apprentice becomes strong enough to kill the master,
he kills the master and then takes an apprentice of his own.
It's been that way for a long, long time.
It's the nature of the Sith that only the strong deserves survive because if the
race is going to survive, it needs to be led by the strongest people. Right.
So not an unreasonable philosophy, but both vessels basically go crashing down,
you know, under the, under the surface of the planet.
And as soon as that happens, right there, kind of like, okay,
obviously Bader is not going to die in a crash. Right. Like that's,
that's never going to happen. So they're like, okay,
let's get out there and let's get Bader. They ended up bringing in like Y wings,
right? Like they're their rebel bombers. Right.
They send out like a battalion of people and then you switch over to princess
Leia and Han solo who does, is kind of like out there. No,
I remember Han solo did come back at the end of a new hope rescue Luke,
but he's still kind of in that position where he's, he's, he's basically like,
okay, I'm on the side of the rebels,
but I still don't really know if I believe in the force yet,
but I'm still trying to bang layer. So like,
I'm going to hang around a little while to see if I can get her between the
sheets, you know? And then like, if I can cool,
then I'll hang around a lot longer. As we know he did. Right.
He got layered between the sheets multiple times. So like we know that happened.
Right. And so at this point when he's talking to her, she's kind of like, okay,
Bader is on, is on Vargans right. He's on, he's on this planet. Right.
Vargas boss. And it's kind of like, okay, initially Han Solo's like,
you guys are gonna go after him because Les is like,
we gotta send a whole battalion of people. Right.
Like we got to send all the rebels that we have there.
We're sending directly to go confront Darth Vader. And she's like,
then we also have general Donna,
who's basically sending an entire battalion to back them up. Right.
So she's like, we're just throwing sheer numbers at Bader,
hoping that we can turn it into a battle of attrition and effectively wear him
down right. To the point that we can essentially overtake him.
Because when you're the rebels and you're talking about a sheer force of nature,
like Darth Vader, that's really all you can hope for is a battle of attrition.
Right. Just wearing him down, just throwing just huge amounts of numbers,
of people at him to the point that he can't overcome everybody. Right.
And that's kind of, what's what,
they're what they're shooting for now for the most part lay is like, okay,
I'm going to go out there. And Han Solo's like dinner.
You're not going out there alone. Right.
I think that what you're doing is stupid, but like, if that's where Luke is,
I'm not letting you go out there by yourself. So again,
this kind of feeds into the notion of Han solo,
caring about more than himself and going in the direction of being someone that
fights for a greater cause than his own individual interest at that particular
point in time. Right.
Kind of the shift of Han solo from becoming a scoundrel in every sense of the
word, both in character development,
as well as kind of how he sees the world moving into a traditional hero. Right.
Right. And so, because of that, you know, he hits up Chewbacca basically says,
okay, we're traveling to Vegas Vos. It's going to be a stupid decision.
Like we're literally going to go against what is in effect the current Lord of
the Sith outside of the emperor. Right. So like Darth Vader,
the second in command, we're going to go fight a man. I don't, you know,
I'm basically doing it for, for, for layer, you know? So like I can,
I can rescue Luke and kind of continue being a hero, that kind of a thing.
But like they're basically going on this mission. And so it was like, okay,
right. As soon as the rebel fleet goes, launching out in that direction,
we switched back over to Darth Vader on this planet.
And as he's here and he begins to emerge,
the why when you start showing up and the initial thought is there's no sign of
Vader. He may have died in the crash, but then they realize she's alive. Right.
They get visual confirmation,
they see them there and Vader's just standing there. And like,
as they come running in with their wide wings and launching a bombing run,
Darth Vader literally uses the force and like picks up these huge chunks of
rocks and just throws them into the ship. Right. Then just,
just like sends these why wins crushing, wind,
crashing into each other and like crashing under the ground like that. Right.
In the span of like one move,
he took out all these Y wings and that's the end of it.
Now for Luke Skywalker himself, he of course survived the,
the entire ordeal along with R2D2.
And at this point is just making his way back to the rest of the group right
now. This is probably the single best moment in the entirety of the story.
Right. It's, it's ridiculously good.
So as Vader's making his way there or making his way to where he believes Lou
Scott Walker should be,
or at least using the force to since looks location and traveling to where he's
at, he suddenly kind of ambushed by all these rebels. And,
and it's kind of interesting because Vader kind of looks around and he says,
okay, so this place is, is, is powerful in the forest, right?
It's not the most powerful place ever.
It's not the most powerful force planet ever, but there is force power here.
This was once the side of a Jedi temple.
It makes sense that Luke would lead the rebellion here, right?
Or the rebellion would be drawn to this location since they are more or less
within the node, not tied to the light side of the forest,
but in suddenly as he's ambushed, all these rebels are just like,
like Darth Vader, lay down your weapons.
You're completely surrounded with the most biggest response ever with the most
Beazer new mountain or chase on the most Bish response ever Darth Vader looks at
them all and says, all I'm surrounded by is fear and dead.
Ben will that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are no here to comments, explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob Horford Carson
drawer, this video, make sure you drop a like, and I will catch you all.
[Inaudible].